hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Jerry we
just came back from watching the visit
that's right yep
the visit about two kids who go to see
their grandparents they've never met
before stay a week with them could
things go wrong
who knows that's M night Shyamalan movie
probably we're critics anyway I had a
total blast watching this film I thought
it was so much fun it had an incredible
sense of humor within two characters
that made an overall tone of the film
like it had its moments of fear it had
its spooky jump scares and whatnot and
those creepy images but it always
followed up with kind of making fun of
it or making a joke about it and stuff
well yeah and and from the kind of from
the second I saw the trailer I thought
to myself like this is the kind of movie
that can only work if they decide to
kind of go weird with it like you know
have a lot of humor but also have some
stuff that's genuinely you know strange
and unsettling and the movie does that
and I think that's you know it's a smart
choice answer service yeah you should
see what these cats can do like we have
like a sound wall here and they're
scaling the determine like fuzzy I
really got a credit M night Shyamalan
here because he knew how to make a found
footage movie actually feel kind of
refreshing in a way I wasn't sitting
there like oh my god another found
footage movie with the same found
footage tricks there are some similar
ones but he knew how to make a good one
though I guess it helps that you have
this conceit of like these kids are sort
of making an amateur documentary like
that does kind of help to fill in a lot
of the gaps stylistically I found
footage and so then you can cheat and
you can have things like Oh an
establishing shot how nice yeah Oh some
actual moody footage I liked how M night
Shyamalan with his script for the girl
Rebecca how she had this like total
filmography kind of dialogue the whole
time and yeah at times it kind of pulled
me out kind of like okay she doesn't
sound like her age at all right there
well that's the thing is is for this
whole movie kind of it was like enough
for the whole movie but it took me a
while to kind of latch on to what they
were doing with the
his characters cuz yeah at first it's
like okay they both have a really
distinct character trait uh
she's all like artsy and into film and
he's you know one of your bad I love
that they're quirky but then as the
movie goes on and it establishes a sense
of humor like it makes sense for them to
be quite a little bit and then it also
again helps us with the visuals because
you know because she's so kind of
arthouse about things we do get some
some nice breaks from found-footage norm
and some tripod and there's and there's
some satire and there there's something
like on the nose humor like when she's
trying to get certain moods or she's
like oh wait that looks very organic let
it happen you know [ __ ] like that yeah
it's almost meta cuz they're
acknowledging the fact that they're
adding these things that are nice to
have in non found-footage movies just to
break up the pace and give us a little
variety and you don't get those usually
and I like when they include them for it
because your night then you got two
cameras pretty early on in the movie
with the boy and I love that kid um
what's his name ed oxen both what what a
[ __ ] name oxen you mean t-diamond
stylus
he plays Tyler and the guy a little
brother little brother man you cats need
to chill the [ __ ] out in camera got
there you know goddamn genre linear time
and copper that kid he rocked this movie
like he did and I thought I was gonna
hate it so tonight I thought I was like
ah he's gonna be that annoying squat in
this film he was gonna be the annoying
one who doesn't ever show up and she's
gonna be like the too smart to be 50s
always I know it at her brother but they
had a rather interesting dynamic the
whole time I I was drawn to their
brother and sister relationship he's too
clearly loved and cared about each other
and there was a bond they had it wasn't
like I hate you because you're gross
there's some stupid yeah they actually
allowed them to sort of you know behave
like a real brother and sister might
because you know it's easy to kind of
boil those down to like each other but
all the time you know they're just kind
of in the situation together and you
know they get along fine until like you
know he starts annoying her at some
point
ya know it was funny we got a lot of
both of those people were clapping at
his jokes in that theater man there is
some great [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean the movie come it's like
it's it's weird it like at first you're
like ooh I don't know and then the movie
just commits to who the characters
aren't commits to the the humor that I
bring out and it starts to it's kind of
like a toned-down funhouse movie to me
cuz even with the grandparents stuff
like we haven't even cover that at all
the grandparents stuff there are moments
where it's genuinely eerie and genuinely
creepy scary yeah and but then they also
knew how to make a sense of humor about
it like the movie wasn't unaware that
this is kind of a silly premise yeah the
movie has a good amount of awareness and
then you know by using humor it also
kind of eases you into the more you know
heightened parts of Shyamalan's ideas
nose eases you into everything yeah it's
hard to play stuff like this that's so
willfully strange and unsettling you
know and and and the tone of this movie
really supports that and it helps I
gotta say like I'm not the biggest fan
of jump scares but I enjoyed the jump
scares in this film cuz they were so fun
when they occurred I could think of one
very particularly good one where I mean
I'm not gonna give it away but I
remember if they get okay jump scares
come in right here okay then you start
thinking of all the possible ways of how
it's going to come but then it came in
the one way I did not suspect it but it
was the most brilliant way but ya know
there's some great jump scares in there
and yeah one [ __ ] movie you know and
everyone did a good job in their acting
there was there was good character
moments - it wasn't a night Shyamalan
trying too hard to be moving and stuff
yeah that's the thing is there a couple
moments they put in like in the middle
of the movie that they give the
characters just enough weight and just
enough of an arc and a reason to explain
it but it also keeps them really upbeat
and fun and I liked how when there was
two of them doing the documentary stuff
you know you got the one from the girl
who's very you know very observant and
very into this and then you got the kid
the boy who's like kinda streets are
like a joke when he also see it's good
because then we get two points of view
on the camera so he sneaks off it's like
she can go find us out information about
the grandparents because you know she's
working on this documentary and we get
exposition in a very sly way yeah and he
just wants to go figure out this [ __ ]
mystery I said well because he's more
weirded out than she is so he's gonna go
off and get us our action
and it's kind of you know it works and I
gotta say the film knows how to mislead
you in a very smart way like a lot of
the times you think something's gonna
happen it doesn't and sometimes you
don't suspect something and then it
happens you know there's some there's
some good surprises in there there's
particularly one moment in the finale
that I know a lot of people are going to
be talking about it's the one gross part
of the finale that's long as they but
it's the grossest mark you'll know what
it is when you see it probably and I
know there'll be a debate but there will
be there was some people who are
clapping when it happened it is a clap
worthy mom yeah I just I wouldn't have
kept it
I just think M night Shyamalan had so
much fun with this movie I feel like he
didn't take himself so [ __ ] seriously
like he tends to you know cuz his movies
are so serious sometimes and it bothers
me and but this one was fun well that's
what's nice about found footage and the
fact that he's in bloom house is like
they take people who kind of could use a
redemption in the in the cinema and also
it's like found-footage forces you to
get away from some of the stylistic
gimmicks you're used to so it's like he
can't draw things out and make them
plotting he kind of has to stick to like
it's real you know ish so I feel like
found flourish is a great waste a great
place to see like what a directors
capable of when their tropes are gone
one last thing I got to say about this
movie is when it had moments because you
know every family movie has those
moments you're like really when they
[ __ ] be recording right now yeah or
come on the camera would have so [ __ ]
died yeah you know I'd [ __ ] like that
like I have that camera I know what
would happen even like 20 minutes from
now I will say it was one of the least
distracting movies to do it yeah it's
like I was more interested like because
of the tone and because of the bits of
story they were giving us I was more
interested in that than the ingenuity of
the you know technique Wow and that's a
good thing sometimes he mixes it up with
some like you know it's like is this
part of the documentary where they're
they're showing cool shots of the sky
and the trees and stuff and like at
times music would play yeah it's like it
has blemishes and things like that here
and there like that where you're like it
doesn't fully alleviate all those
problems like sometimes you're like
where did that shot come from I can kind
of take it an educated guess but yeah
you know or why would they still be
filming this or certain things like that
it's it's not that they're not there but
yeah like a lot of the time it does
pretty good job of at least making it
believable absolutely a lot of the time
I had a great time people apparently
can't comprehend a review unless there's
a rating system some people are like you
need a rating system I mean you know
generally positive you know it's got
some some missteps here and there but
it's generally positive I say it got
five left testicles um out of five five
out of five five out of five Wow is high
praise yeah I'm the left testicle that's
the dominant one I mean out of five I
don't know three and a half maybe four
like I enjoyed my loser testicles we're
talking about if we're talking about
like rhinestones it's like three out of
five I'm very I would love to see a
breakdown if you're really my rating
systems are very well thought-out Jerry
it's good go see it like it's not
entirely order favor time man yeah it's
not entirely perfect but it's got enough
you know horror movie stuff and it's got
enough you know fun personality and
quirkiness that kind of transcends all
the you know little mistakes here and
there and it's a fun movie to go with
with black people
anybody who's responsive to the screen
really if that's I know but we had the
black route not predominantly yeah in
the rows behind us the ones who were
screaming the ones in making people
laughing look are you just making a
generalization hey she sounded black B I
turned around and yes in fact she was of
african-american descent okay yeah and
she was hollering and everything uh yeah
everybody in that theater seem to be
hollering at some point hell I was I was
pretty audible during the therapy
actually yeah but I'm saying that it
like people this is really bring you in
this is the kind of movie war for the
first half hour you're gonna be laughing
at things because you're like huh this
movie and then after that point you
actually start to laugh with the movie
yeah and that's that's usually yeah yeah
at first it was like this kind of all
like this is kind of weird especially
when you know Shyamalan because you're
like okay there's humor now but it's
about to get dead Syria doesn't do that
this is this is the thing this is
clearly from the guy who thought of the
happening yeah but it's a much better
absolutely like this is kind of a weird
premise but it could work and it doesn't
end that it worked you can see how there
might be the same dude with those
concepts but he's improved absolutely
this step in the right direction
I'm not Shyamalan you have reinstalled
faith anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to it you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out reasons to Jerry and dank
a Stubbs both shows hosted by none other
than the Jerry Bader and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope and maybe one day we'll get a
snapchat but the last time I got
snapchat its girl sent me her tits and I
was like oh yeah yeah and that's how you
shot at it and then I used it against
her saying like you [ __ ] with me one
more time [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ] release
this photo of you you understand [ __ ]
and then she was like this ya know and
then I put my foot down I said threat I
said girl don't make me put my foot up
your ass you won't mint some fans need
to be put in their place this is
terrible this is making you sound like a
monster no these are [ __ ] it's okay to
tar they like being talked to everything
we are not going to have the
slut-shaming conversation I'm kidding
what say people too